après la roumanie emmanuel macron est
arrivé en moldavie ce pays l'un des plus
pauvres d'europe est en première ligne
dans le conflit ukrainien il a accueilli
plus de 400 mille réfugiés dont près de
100 mille d'entre eux se trouvent encore
sur le territoire moldave je veux dire
ici mesdames et messieurs
l'admiration de la france face à l'élan
de solidarité et de générosité
dont a fait preuve la population moldave
en accueillant les personnes qui ont dû
fuir le conflit en ukraine et avec 15
millions d'euros d'aidé budgétaire plus
d'un million d'euros dettes d'urgence 37
tonnes de matériel des ambulances qui
seront d'ailleurs livré dans quelques
jours la france est l'un des premiers
soutiens à la moldavie et cet appui j'en
prends ici l'engagement se poursuivre un
peu plus tôt le président français
étaient en roumanie il s'est rendu sur
une base de l'otan où se trouve 500
soldats français déployés en urgence
début mars après l'invasion russe en
ukraine emmanuel macron a voulu remettre
les choses au clair il n'a aucune
complaisance envers la russie mais les
négociations restent selon lui le seul
moyen de mettre un terme à la guerre à
un moment donné quand nous aurons aider
au maximum à résister quand je le
souhaite le crès n'aura gagné surtout
que le feu pourra cesser nous devrons
négocier
président ukrainien ses dirigeants devra
négocier avec la russie le président
français a rappelé le soutien sans
faille de l'union européenne envers les
ukrainiens mais on ne sait toujours pas
s'il poursuivra son voyage vers kiev
alors que la france occupe la présidence
de lieux emmanuel macron reste à ce jour
l'un des rares dirigeants européens à ne
pas s'être encore rendue en ukraine
le cren qui